I would like to give a special thank you
to the 45th president Donald Trump and a
Supreme Court Justice picks because
affirmative action has been ruled
unconstitutional affirmative action is a
racist policy I stand firmly against it
and I'm glad to see that the correct
ruling was handed down we'll see where
this goes already these universities are
trying to find loopholes and workarounds
to keep using race as a pretext for your
admission into these schools and it's
and it's horrifying you should not be
able to use someone's race to determine
whether or not they're able to go to a
higher learning facility not that I'm a
big fan of colleges as it is but this is
an amazing ruling and we got to see how
where it goes beyond just these
universities so it should be
particularly big news so we're gonna be
talking about that quite a bit we do
have a bit of other news Donald Trump's
response to this as well as Dylan
Mulvaney addressing the Bud Light Fiasco
that's right because Bud Light will uh
will always be in the news so we'll uh
we'll talk about that but I do think the
affirmative action thing is going to be
a really really big